make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so too powerful for Marvel movies
in this video we're covering unstoppable
Colossus now in order to understand this
there are a couple things we need to
know the first is a being named Syd Iraq
and the second is an event that Marvel
had called fear itself now fear itself
is an event that we have covered you'll
find the link down in the description my
editor Gordon will put it down there for
you guys to check out fear itself was a
story that basically revealed that there
was another heir to the throne of Asgard
right like for years and years and years
in Marvel Comics it was only ever just
Odin and in the ideal is it Odin in his
younger days they basically went to go
fight Serdar alongside his brothers
villian v villian V died
Odin absorbed their life energy and then
basically had the odinforce and then
like defeated Serdar
and that was basically it and went on
that way for like decades in Marvel
Comics what fear itself revealed is that
there was actually a third brother by
the name of Cole and Cole was was
according to his stance the rightful
heir to the throne of Asgard and it
basically had stolen from them by Odin
more or less and so what ended up
happening is that Cole also called the
serpent essentially like launched a
campaign to conquer earth and then
attack asgaard and in the process
created like a whole bunch of hammers
which fell to various people across the
world the Incredible Hulk juggernaut
different characters like that now in
terms of how this ties in to unstoppable
Colossus this goes into the nature of
juggernaut in sin Iraq so in Marvel
Comics you've got all different kinds of
dimensions right like you have the Dark
Dimension which is where Dormammu
resides
you've got like like nightmare dimension
which is where the being nightmare is I
he's literally fuelled by all the
nightmares that everybody has throughout
the entire universe and then you have
the crimson cosmos and the crimson
cosmos is this dimension this house by a
guy named Sid Iraq and sin Iraq is just
a super powerful being right like he
occupied earth at one point he was
banished and then took up residence in
his own little dimension where he's
crazy powerful but he like a lot of
other entities out there will lend their
power to people and so during the Korean
War when you had Professor Charles
Xavier and his brother Cain Marko who
discovered a temple and then of course
in this temple was the crimson gem of
cyttorak when Cain Marko took it he
became the juggernaut right like you was
a whole inscription you know you who
read these words shall go forward
forevermore a human juggernaut and so on
and so forth the idea is that sinner act
by his nature is very like covets his
power right like he's very very selfish
in terms of how his power functions and
so on and so forth and only ever wants
one avatar a ton and so during the
events of fear itself when the hammers
fell to earth and juggernaut picked one
up he basically had the power sit Iraq
and the power of this hammer the result
was that in order for the x-men to
defeat juggernaut Colossus and his
sister magic went to the the dimension
of the Crimson cosmos and then spoke
directly to sit Iraq and said hey look
so like juggernaut has your power and
another guy's power as well and the
result was that said Iraq got pissed and
he took the power of the juggernaut away
from from Cain Marko and then gave it to
Colossus and Colossus in turn had his
mutant abilities the osmium medal that
he transforms into when he goes into his
metallic form combined with the power of
the juggernaut now there are a couple
caveats to this of course one of the
rules in Marvel Comics is that once the
juggernaut starts moving he cannot be
stuck now this is courses is contextual
once the juggernaut starts moving it
cannot be stopped except by like
somebody crazy powerful right like a
reality manipulator or someone who's
like a super high-level telekinetic who
can just lift him into the air or
something along those lines there's
people that can overcome that but in
terms of like sheer force a person
cannot physically stop the juggernaut
from running the only exception to that
was during the events of Peter David's
run on the Incredible Hulk when Hulk
became the horseman war by apocalypse
and of course at that point he was able
to like stop Colossus removing the
caveat to that was that he was basically
powered by like the entirety of the
heroes reborn universe right so it was
basically the it was the Incredible Hulk
powered by a universe stopping the
juggernaut from moving so that's really
all that was he was super powerful in
terms of what he was capable of but the
factory-made that's like the only the
only moment that I'm aware of in Marvel
Comics where someone's been able to use
physical strength to stop the juggernaut
from moving having said that with
Colossus having that kind of power oh he
was nuts it was it was crazy how
powerful he was because one he was
almost completely indestructible wasn't
completely indestructible but he was
highly durable with his osmium skin
Riley he could survive extreme
temperatures and like like from super
hot to super cold in terms of like
physical attacks with the exception of
like a handful of different things like
anti metal which is basically like
Arctic vibranium Magneto's ability to
control metal pilars of course as well
would be with the exception of a few
things like that Colossus was for the
most part almost completely
indestructible and he was highly durable
did you go into him being having all
that stuff amplified by the juggernaut
by the joining up Howard right so that
means he's basically like in
indestructible he cannot physically be
stuck uh he's indestructible he has
insane levels of strength um again like
once he starts moving you can't really
slow him down so
it was kind of a crazy battle between
himself and Jonah and it played out
really really well again the videos down
in the description if you guys want to
go check it out but throwing that kind
of character into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe there are ways to stop them and
that's kind of the big difference here
is that when it comes to the unstoppable
Colossus he is by and large for the most
part too powerful for the MCU in its
current form but it does not mean he's
too powerful for the MCU in like a
future form specifically somebody like
Jean Grey now the funny thing about this
is that with Colossus while he's in his
metal form he's not immune to telepathy
but with the power of the juggernaut he
for the most part is you have to remove
his helmet in order to basically use
telepathic attacks on him that's one of
the caveats of the juggernaut is when he
has this helmet on he can't really be
attached telepathically it's a witness
happening for Colossus in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you would need the
x-men that that's literally what you
would need you we need the x-men team in
order to defeat him and even then it
wouldn't take like the super powerful
cared ruling it wouldn't take a whole
host of x-men to do it you would need
some heavy hitters right like you would
need a Jean Grey with like the powers of
the Phoenix or at her highest level with
telekinesis before she was the Phoenix
via The Incredible Hulk
somebody who could attack with ranged
attacks you probably need like Cyclops
but yeah I mean between those three
because what you could do is you can
have Jean Grey lift him into the air and
then pull the helmet off of him assuming
your two left her telekinesis was strong
enough to do it but she could pull the
helmet off of Colossus and then in turn
like hit him with telepathic attacks at
the very least the the optic beams of
Cyclops depending on how strong they are
could like offer a distraction they
wouldn't really be able to slow him down
but they could offer a distraction and
then in turn you kind of have the
Incredible Hulk just pummeling you no
but then again you could bring in Thor
but the funny thing about this is that
in the old school days of Marvel Comics
it's long since changed but in the old
school days of Marvel Comics juggernaut
had kind of a force field around them
and so there was one story where Thor
threw his hammer at juggernaut trying to
hit him and the hammer just bounced off
because of the force field so like
juggernaut was immune to like the hammer
of Thor if they bring that over
well then Thor won't really be of any
use I mean he could punch really hard
and hit hard but in terms of like
actually being able to impact anything
with his hammer there wouldn't really be
a whole lot he could do but again like
you could take ensemble Colossus out
that way
again like like using telepathy to kind
of infiltrate his brain and basically
like shut him down or any number of
things and that's that's happened before
but even then like you just grabbed
Magneto
I need it would be one of the best ways
to do it use magneto to pull the helmet
off of him and then like then literally
like like go into his brain have Jean
Grae enter his head and do it
she wants to do you know and and
something happens and then it turned
like have magneto shut down the actual
Colossus element like the metal like
disrupt that thing that's what happened
during the events of mutant massacre
right like Colossus was injured there
was something to happen to God it's been
so long Colossus was injured uh magneto
tried to basically do something to heal
him to like move his his metal out of
the way and ended up like disrupting it
and so basically like Colossus could
really transform for a little while you
could I mean those guys right there
could defeat unstoppable Colossus but
you would need someone like like The
Incredible Hulk to intervene the issue
with this is that while the Incredible
Hulk is strong The Incredible Hulk isn't
really powerful enough to like stop
juggernaut or stop ensemble Colossus by
himself right like just using sheer
strength you wouldn't be able to pull it
off because again like once juggernaut
starts moving it can't be stopped so you
would need like either augmentation or
you would need them all kind of fighting
at the same time but again I think Jean
Grey is the key using her telekinesis
Jean Grey Magneto I think will be the
the one-two punch to be able to take out
unstoppable Colossus but in terms of the
the current form of the MCU Colossus
would just crush everybody nobody was
saying a chance because one of the
things that you have to keep in mind is
that even if you kind of look to the
Incredible Hulk and Thor Thor strike
does not infinite right like he has a
finite like a point like the strength he
has now is as strong as he gets unless
he goes Berserker and even going
Berserker he wouldn't be able to defeat
like unstoppable Colossus so then you
would have to look at the Incredible
Hulk but the issue is that the
Incredible Hulk strength starts out at a
baseline level and then works its way up
and so with unstoppable Colossus by the
nature of the juggernaut being what he
is having a higher level of strike that
the Incredible Hulk when he first
transforms then like the fight would
have to go on long enough for the
Incredible Hulk strength to reach
Colossus and then get higher in order to
like overpower but again like we haven't
really seen that unless he was augmented
and had the power of a universe behind
him if you did that with the x-men
magneto Jean Grey you know and and then
through it like the Incredible Hulk
you could win well you could definitely
went but if in its current form you'd
have to rely on someone like Tony start
to create like some super high-end
magnets or something like that to like
pull the helmet off of it which I'd love
to see II think I'd love to see Tony
Stark come running up on unsolveable
Colossus was like one of those giant
horse shaped horse horseshoe magnets and
like try to pull it off and he look like
a Looney tune character if he did it'd
be hilarious but I would love to see
that I think it'd be fun I think it'd be
hilarious to see but again like it is in
its current form unsolvable Colossus
would decimate the entirety of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as a stands
now it wouldn't even be a fight Lowe
would even be fair it would be an ad
like let you be a murdering is what it
would be but so in the x-men and
suddenly everything changes because the
the powers of the team are designed to
overcome various characters depending on
lookout load what abilities they have
but working in tandem and kind of
putting them in awkward pairs you can
overcome a lot of different foes or you
normally wouldn't be able to see the
x-men take out so anyway without being
said guys let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]